mon invité est plutôt du genre précoce
il a été élu conseiller municipal dès
l'âge de 19 ans premier adjoint au maire
à 27 ans et retiré de la politique à 32
l'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là mais
il a replongé pour devenir député
[Musique]
bonjour Stéphane Viry bonjour alors en
1989 vous avez été le plus jeune
conseiller municipal de France élus dans
l'équipe de Philips Seguin à Épinal et
vous avez découvert à l'époque ce qu'est
la vie d'un élu local on a retrouvé
votre témoignage recueilli en 1992 vous
aviez alors 22 ans témoignage recueillis
par nos confrères d'image plus
je m'étais pas fait à l'idée de d'être
un peu l'assistante sociale de tout un
quartier d'Épinal ou bien nous
solliciter parce que le fossé n'a pas
été curé parce que le ramassage des
ordures ménagères a été fait à une heure
après etc et je n'avais pas du tout ceci
moi le ramassage des ordures ménagères
ou le suicide a des papiers qui traînent
dans la rue ils se font ça c'était pas
ce que ce qui m'intéressait le plus dans
une activité municipales mais il y aura
que c'est important on a l'impression
vous aviez un peu idéalisé ce que ce qui
était le fait d'être un homme politique
local et que bah vous avez découvert une
réalité un peu un peu différente ouais
c'était une vraie découverte parce que
mon engagement en fait c'est le fait du
hasard c'était pas programmé pour cela
une proposition en 1989 d'être sur la
liste d'un homme que j'admirais en tant
que mère d'Épinal je rejoins son équipe
je suis élu alors que c'était pas
forcément prévu et puis effectivement on
idéalise peut-être un peu l'action la
façon de d'être positif la façon de
construire des projets et on s'aper que
l'attente la tente citoyenne elle est un
peu différente mais ça a été une très
belle école je ne je ne regrette rien et
je crois que ça a construit ma
personnalité mon parcours ce côté
assistant de social que vous évoquez
dans dans ce reportage il existe aussi
quand on est député ça fait partie du
job on a fait partie ça fait partie dans
l'imagerie populaire effectivement de la
fonction de député même si
statutairement c'est pas ça le député il
est là pour voter la loi pour contrôler
l'action du gouvernement pour défendre
un territoire mais on est énormément
sollicité par des citoyens qui viennent
demander qu'on accélère un dossier qu'on
rétablisse des droits qu'on les écoute
tout simplement ça fait partie de la
fonction et c'est un moment que
j'apprécie être au contact sondé se
faire engueuler c'est aussi un moyen de
vous sentir utile de sentir utile et
puis peut-être parfois de d'apaiser
souvent on est le dernier recours
souvent on est à la dernière oreille
parfois on apporte la solution pas
toujours parce qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas
tout pouvoir parfois il y a des citoyens
qui viennent nous pourra pas se droit là
j'ai plus de difficultés c'est pas parce
qu'on est député qu'on doit favoriser
contourner la loi pour obtenir des des
faveurs mais je pense que notre fonction
elle est effectivement de chercher à
apaiser à expliquer à faire en sorte
qu'on soit un peu mieux dans ce dans ce
collectif dernier détail mais ça m'a
marqué donc je vous pose la question
quand vous parlez là vous avez 22 ans on
a l'impression que vous en avez 15 de
plus comme si vous étiez presque
ministre vous avez toujours été comme ça
c'est dans je sais pas peut-être la
caméra me faisait d'être un peu sérieux
à l'époque il est possible que dans les
premières années de la vie on se sent un
peu investi d'une mission qu'on a pas
non je pense pas avoir été en tout cas
ça accéléré à côté simplement ma vie
lorsqu'on a élu aux côtés d'un mec comme
Sega toute façon toute façon dans ta
façon de penser de te construire de
regarder la France donc j'ai peut-être
été un peu plus exigeant sur sur moi sur
des choses
je ne sais pas je pourrais pas vous dire
précisément bon on va en parler de
Philippe Séguin justement parce que vous
l'avez dit il a joué un rôle clé dans
votre engagement politique
vous l'avez évoqué d'un mot mais comment
ça s'est fait déjà pour vous comment
vous êtes retrouvé sur cette liste au
municipale je vais être un peu cavalier
parce que un casting je pense qu'à
l'époque l'idée c'est d'avoir un jeune
ou deux jeunes sur salés j'avais été
membre du conseil des jeunes de la ville
d'épinards j'avais peut-être fait
quelques actions sympas je m'étais
peut-être fait un peu repérer et donc
quelques semaines avant les élections on
te propose de rejoindre l'équipe d'être
dans une position a priori inéligible
plutôt enfin liste et c'est gains ont
été à très bon maire d'Épinal a été
plébiscités par les Spinaliens je me
suis retrouvé donc embarqué dans cette
dans cette très belle aventure et j'ai
appris j'ai découvert j'avais 19 ans et
était plongé dans un monde alors
effectivement d'adulte
ça c'est compliqué à 19h alors que tu es
étudiante tu as envie de détecter tes
potes tu as envie d'avoir suivi vous
études en parallèle mais toutes mes
études en parallèle mais tu te retrouves
dans des commissions évidemment sérieux
évidemment importante Philippe
travaillait sur les finances publiques
effectivement demandé d'être rapporteur
général des budgets de la ville d'Épinal
à 19 ans donc tu te mets dans des
bouquins dont tu imaginez pas qu'il
puisse exister à l'époque je ne dirais
que l'argent de poche de mes parents
donc ça a été voilà des moments des
moments forts des moments qui voilà qui
m'ont construit et des belles rencontres
et vous dites il m'a façonné sans le
dire qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il a
façonné en vous qu'est-ce que vous avez
gardé de lui dans sa façon de faire de
la politique je l'ai beaucoup lu je l'ai
écouté je l'ai observais je l'ai côtoyé
j'ai eu des moments un peu privilégiés
probablement avec lui pendant plusieurs
années des apartés comme cela et il
était assez puissant à ce moment-là au
niveau de la France il a mais sur le
titre très largement contribué à
l'élection Jacques Chirac il avait une
vision du pays de la République de
l'égalité des chances de la cohésion
sociale je pense que quand je raisonne
actuellement politique par rapport à des
choix qui sont parfois compliqués je
pense que j'ai cette ADN en 1995 il a
fait de vous son adjoint finance et deux
ans plus tard il a quitté Épinal pour se
consacrer un peu à sa carrière politique
nationale prenant la tête du RPR et on
se projetant vers cette candidature au
municipale à Paris est-ce qu'au moment
de Épinal il vous a proposé de prendre
sa succession à la mairie la question
avait été évoquée après c'était pas à
mon tour et c'était pas ma place moi
j'avais l'idée de vivre autrement que
par la vie politique il y avait à
l'époque Michel enrich qui était un très
bon premier adjoint il fallait respecter
l'ordre des choses et puis vous savez
moi je peux vivre sans politique moi je
suis pas addict à la politique je ne
regrette absolument pas ces premières
parties de ma vie professionnelle que
j'ai dévolue à cette action pour Épinal
après je n'avais pas l'idée
effectivement de faire ça toute ma vie
alors justement après le départ de
Philippe Seguin vous avez été le premier
adjoint du nouveau maire Michel Henry je
voulais évoquer et puis en 2001 à l'âge
où certains entrent en politique bah
Vous vous la quittez pourquoi mais parce
que parce que j'avais envie de d'être
autonome et je voulais pas dépendre de
la vie politique la vie politique c'est
une mission tu es tu es un mandat pour
exercer un certain un certain temps moi
je dis que politique c'est pas c'est pas
une profession c'est quelque chose que
tu accomplis à un moment donné parce que
tu t'es mis candidat et que les suffra
qui ont été accordées moi je voulais pas
mais dépendant de cela et puis j'avais
fait des études de droit et puis j'avais
envie de m'installer j'avais envie
d'exercer la profession d'avocat et je
ne voulais pas faire les deux choses en
même temps donc j'ai cette décision
effectivement de me retirer de tout
engagement politique qu'est-ce que c'est
possible parce que vous aviez perdu un
peu la flamme j'ai lu cette phrase de
vous à l'époque je n'ai plus la
motivation me permettant de contracter
un engagement pour une durée de 6 ans ça
donne l'impression que ouais mais je
crois que c'est normal et puis je
pourrais quasiment vous dire la même
chose avec la fonction que j'exerce
actuellement moi
évidemment on a la flamme l'enthousiasme
parfois l'Argonne d'aller chercher des
choses d'aller prendre tout ce qu'on
peut prendre pour pour les citoyens
après c'est ce sont des fonctions qui
sont astreignantes qui sont parfois
douloureuses qui sont parfois
frustrantes et il faut me semble-t-il
avoir toujours effectivement au fond de
soi cette volonté cette capacité
physique psychique à aller chercher
quelque chose
voilà je m'étais engagé à 19 ans je
n'avais trop un an 12 ans à cet âge-là
c'était la fin d'un cycle je pense que
c'était la pharmacie que j'aspir faire
autre chose alors cette autre chose ça a
pris la forme six ans plus tard d'une
autre forme d'engagement on va dire très
différente en tant que président du club
de foot d'Épinal que vous avez fait
passer de CFA2 à national en National
est-ce que vous voyez des points communs
entre la politique et l'engagement
associatif sportif oui c'est pour moi la
même chose tu te donnes de ton temps
pour pour une cause commune pour autre
chose
quand tu t'engages dans une association
que ça soit une amicale de parents
d'élèves un comité des fêtes un comité
d'entreprise ou tout autre association
tu le fais pas pour toi tu le fais pour
pour autrui dans la politique tu le fais
par rapport à Amanda par rapport à une
fonction institutionnelle dans une
association à un moment donné on te
propose de porter un club associatif bah
tu prends le projet tu le crées et tu
essaies d'embarquer à toi des bénévoles
des forces vives qui ont qui ont
peut-être la même idée que toi de de
faire avancer les choses donc la
politique c'est la même chose me
semble-t-il vous dites que vous avez
vécu en tant président de club les
meilleurs moments de votre vie je
confirme ça veut dire que vous y avez
trouvé des choses que la politique ne
pouvait pas vous apporter quoi peut-être
la simplicité peut-être peut-être de la
générosité humaine le club de foot
d'Épinal c'est une très belle histoire
je parle pas des résultats je parle pas
du sportif on se retrouve avec des
bénévoles dans un comité dans un comité
directeur on est tous différents mais on
a cette idée effectivement de bosser
pour pour ce club tu as des moments de
doute tu as des nuits blanches en tant
que président comment je vais faire pour
telle situation tu as des contraintes du
quotidien à minibus pour amener les
gamins le samedi mais ça j'en ai trouvé
au fond de moi un épanouissement très
profond très sincère et si j'ai une
sensation qui me manque actuellement
c'est bien celle-ci alors par la suite
vous avez eu d'autres engagements
associatifs au sein de la Fondation agir
contre l'exclusion et avec l'association
Jeunesse et culture qui fait de la
prévention auprès des jeunes
finalement est-ce que c'est pas là que
vous êtes le plus heureux dans ce côté
qu'on évoquait au début de l'émission de
assistant social non mais je pense que
j'aime ça vous savez on a tous une
vocation
moi j'aime le collectif j'aime avancer
des idées j'aime chercher à trouver des
solutions mais pas pour moi pour des
causes pour pour des objectifs peut-être
parfois pour des utopies vous êtes quand
même revenir en politique en 2014 au
côté donc du député maire d'Épinal
michelinrich c'était dans la perspective
du non-cumul des mandats il savait qu'il
allait de voir laisser l'un de ces deux
mandats mère ou députés et il vous a
proposé entre guillemets pas de choisir
mais en tout cas de de décider où vous
tenteriez votre chance vous avez choisi
les législatives pour devenir député
pourquoi parce que pour moi c'est
l'histoire de France c'est la
Constituante c'est probablement le droit
en étant avocat c'est peut-être tes
réflexes que j'ai mais sans aucun doute
c'est ce sont les actions législatives
donc on s'inscrit effectivement dans
cette idée qu'à terme parce que je
rentre en 2014 que 4 termes pour 2017 je
puisse potentiellement obtenir une
investiture
c'était l'idée de voir où on allait
aller et on est allé effectivement
l'investiture en 2017 allez c'est
l'heure de notre quiz à présent je vous
explique le principe je vais vous
proposer de comp trouver des phrases qui
sont en lien un peu avec votre histoire
votre parcours on y va on y va c'est
Philippe Séguin était encore président
de l'Assemblée nationale et le serait
devenu président de la République ah je
pensais que vous alliez dire dans la
façon de gérer les débats aujourd'hui
dans cette émission un peu agité comment
ça se passerait avec lui il serait
probablement malheureux parce qu'il
aimait profondément cette institution
il serait à mon avis à plus autoritaire
que la présente actuelle jouer au foot
aux côtés de députés LFI ou RN aucun
problème aucun problème
je continue à faire du foot dans un club
à côté d'Épinal c'est un moment de
rayonnement un vestiaire on n'a pas
d'identité on n'a pas de fonction on n'a
pas d'âge on n'a pas de statut on
partage un truc moi j'aime cette
fraternité j'aime ce sport et alors
qu'on porte à Mayo mes collègues et les
filles ou RN ils ont été élus par le
suffrage universel je vais pas les
distinguer je vais pas avoir
d'appartenance j'avais des invité à
Épinal à inviter François Ruffin à venir
faire un match de foot avec mon équipe
de vétérans le sport c'est autre chose
le sport c'est autre chose il faut
respecter les fondamentaux être député
c'est renoncer à une partie de soi-même
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué j'ai
compris non mais c'est faut bien mesurer
les conséquences que ça peut avoir pour
tes proches pour tes enfants pour ta vie
d'à côté donc être député c'est renoncer
quasiment tout le reste et du coup il y
aura pas de troisième mandat pour vous
je m'inscris pas dans la durée j'ai pas
l'idée de finir ma montant professionnel
mon activité professionnelle dans une
action politique je l'ai toujours dit
j'ai l'idée de proposer autre chose une
autre contribution après c'est pas
encore quoi nous verrons bien merci
beaucoup Stéphane Viry d'être venu dans
la politique et moi merci à vous
[Musique]